Okay.
So we're going to finish up on nuclear fillic substitution elimination reactions
today,
uh,
with,
and have an example of a practical application of them and then go on to the
reverse reaction of,
of,
uh,
of elimination,
which is addition to alkenes.
So a new functional group and we'll be talking about the stability of them
today.
The stability alkenes.
Okay.
So,
uh,
last time we got,
we got started on,
uh,
the silver assisted a substitution reaction of neopentyl iodide.
And notice something interesting in this.
If we look at those red crosses that trace the carbon skeleton of the starting
material and the product,
what do you notice about the carbon skeleton?
Does it look like a normal substitution?
Ellen,
what do you say?
No.
Why?
There's not an extra carbon.
There are five carbons on the left and there five carpets on the right,
but they're not hooked together the same way.
Right?
So there's be it been a rearrangement of the carbon skeleton during this
reaction.
So how did this happen?
Well,
silver comes down and pulls off iodide,
right?
Which would then generate this cad.
I am,
but in the cad I,
and we have a low Lumo obviously on the,
uh,
on the cat ionic carbon,
but there are homos next door.
They're not very high homos there,
the CEC Sigma bonds.
But you could imagine that since primary cad ions are rather unstable,
and we'll give some more evidence on this later on that you could get,
uh,
a rearrangement in which first the homo next door is shared with the,
with the Lumo of the carbon cat iron.
Did you ever see a structure like that before where the pair of electrons is
shared with an adjacent Adam?
That's the why bond,
right?
The three center to electron bond,
right.
And then it could keep going,
which would give the tertiary cad ion a carbon with three other carbon carbon
cad.
I end with three other carbons attached to it,
which is much more stable than the primary,
uh,
cad ion is in fact,
it's,
it's possible that it doesn't even go that way,
that,
that at the same time the iodide is leaving and beginning to develop this
unstable primary cad ion.
The methyl next door should shift across so that you directly get the cat ionic
rearrangement product.
But at any rate,
once you have the carbons rearranged like that,
a simple matter to have,
uh,
and notice what that means is that the sigma of the carbon carbon sigma bond is
actually acting as a nucleophile in a displacement reaction,
right?
The carbon next door,
his backside attack as the iodide is leaving,
but it's within the molecule that the reaction is occurring.
Okay?
But then you can bring water down of course,
and finally lose a proton,
which will give the product that the crucial thing is this rearrangement because
the fact of the rearrangement shows that there must've been a cat eye and
intermediate without that cat die.
And there would've been no means for the rearrangement to take place in the
carbon skeleton.
Carbon skeletons don't normally rearrange,
but when you lose electrons and can get these two center to two electron,
three center bonds,
then carbon could move from one place to the adjacent one.
So the fact of the rearrangement shows that this was an sn one reaction,
that there was a cat eye.
And intermediate if to had there been no Canada,
I end intermediate,
there couldn't have been a rearrangement.
Okay,
let's think just a second about the rearrangement.
So we have,
uh,
about this,
three,
three center to electron bond.
So we could imagine bringing a proton down,
mixing with the Pi electrons to form a three,
uh,
three center to electron bond.
We could also imagine bringing into hydrogen down on one end of an Alkene,
uh,
to form a normal kind of cad ion.
And of course it could go on the other end too.
Now the question is,
you could get from one of these to the next by shifting the hydrogen from left
to right.
Okay.
That's the rearrangement.
But the question,
is it,
is it a single minimum or is it a double minimum?
Do you have two normal cad ions which have a transition state?
They can go across,
back and forth between them that's not too high because it has this,
uh,
three center to electron bond or might it be that that bridged structure is in
fact the lowest energy structure and it's a single minimum.
Okay.
So you can do a,
uh,
simple calculations to check this and you may or may not believe them,
but these,
these particular ones are well supported by experimental evidence that we don't
have time to go into right now.
Uh,
but if you,
if you take the open compound,
that's what it's homo looks like,
and you notice that the homo,
which you would have guessed from the structure on the top is the sigma ch bond,
right?
In fact is mixed with some of the electron density in that homo or homo minus
one it is,
is,
is shared over onto the,
uh,
cat ionic carbon,
right?
It's distorted.
You can see that,
that the electrons are shifting that way.
And the Lumo is the other way around that there's some vacancy of the,
of the orbitals that are involved in the ch bond,
right?
So you can imagine that resonance structure,
the one that's drawn in color just below to the right,
but you could also have this structure,
which is a proton plus a carbon carbon double bond.
Or You could have a resonance structure that has a long stretched bond.
Remember when you draw a resonance structures,
you don't move the nuclei,
right?
So it's,
you don't draw that hydrogen over on the right,
right?
You draw it with a really long bond cause they have to be in the same position.
And if you take those three simultaneously into the,
into account,
it says you can have positive charge either on the right carbon,
on the hydrogen or on the left carbon.
So that's what's denoted by drawing this why that the two electrons are shared
among these three centers.
And the positive charge therefore is shared.
And we can see it in the orbitals that that's the way it works.
And of course it makes sense that you should have that.
Of course,
the Cah Sigma bond isn't a very high homo,
so it's not drastically shifted,
not 50 50.
However,
if,
uh,
and we call that the stabilization due to that Homo Lumo mixing hyper
conjugation,
I think we've talked about that before.
And incidentally,
that's one of the factors that makes highly substituted carbon cat I and stable.
Because if you have a carbon next door,
not a,
if you have a hydrogen next door,
right,
there's no way that the electrons involved in that bond can stay,
can mix with the p orbital,
the vacant p orbital because there are thugs funnel.
But if you have a carbon and then a bond,
the electrons in that bond can overlap.
So the more carbons you have attached to this carbon,
the more bonds there are.
That can be who's electrons can be stabilized by mixing with the vacant orbital.
So that hyper conjugation is one reason that more substituted cat ions are more
stable.
Right now if we go to the bridge structure,
which is actually symmetrically bridged,
although the program drew that,
uh,
for its own reasons,
with a different kind of bond.
And if we look at the Homo,
you can see that it's symmetrical.
You can see it's the,
uh,
it's the Pi orbital,
but it's distorted because the,
the hydrogen orbital is mixed with it,
right?
And the Lumo is,
is the,
uh,
is the Po the anti-bonding combination or the Lumo plus one in this case.
So you can see those,
how those orbitals participate.
Okay.
But in fact,
in this calculation,
it's a double minimum.
The,
the,
uh,
open structure is lower in energy than the bridge structure.
So it's a double minimum,
but it's different if you have,
instead of a hydrogen on the top,
you have a methyl group on top because the methyl has a somewhat bigger orbital
than hydrogen does.
So it's better at overlapping two neighbors that hydrogen was okay.
So now it turns out to be a single minimum.
That's the lowest energy structure.
And again,
you can see the homo,
which is a p orbital on the carbon overlapping with pie and the Lumo,
which I put in only because I've been drawing these things,
but I wouldn't spend a lot of time worrying about that one.
But at any rate,
it's a single minimum.
So that,
so that,
that structure is in fact bridge.
Now here I've added,
I've made the Alkene,
the CC double bond unsymmetrical such that the carbon cad I,
and it would be more stable on one side than on the other.
One side is more substituted.
Right?
And in this case it distorts so that it's sort of a double minimum,
but that one side is very low,
right?
So it's an unsymmetrical,
a cat eye and open,
not,
not strongly bridged.
That's its structure.
And there's the,
the homo,
which again is,
uh,
is,
is somewhat mixed,
but I don't waste time looking at those things.
I just put them in because I had him.
Hey.
But anyhow,
it's a sort of double minimum in the sense that it's not a bridge bridge
structure,
but it's,
but it's a unsymmetrical and open.
Okay.
Now a sn one and he won a,
there's an interesting thing about the stereochemistry of sn one reactions.
So you can,
if you substitute the chloride here on this tertiary chloride,
you could imagine,
uh,
getting either the,
Ooh group substitute and directly where the chloride was,
or the Oah group on the opposite face from,
of the chlorine.
Now what would you expect if it was sn one
what about if the sn one,
so the rate determining step is I and his Asian,
you've got a cat eye in intermediate.
What structure do you expect for a carbon cat?
[inaudible] we talked about this last semester in x h three so it's the same
electronic,
same number of electrons is BH three right there?
No electrons in that fourth orbital.
What should that orbital be?
Right?
They're there for atomic orbitals on the carbon or bore on and Bh three right?
But you don't,
you only have electrons in three of them,
right?
How should you hybridize it as p two to get the strongest bonds and leave the
vacancy in the highest energy?
Orbital,
the p orbital.
So it should be plainer.
Now,
if you get a plane or intermediate,
how much attack should be from one side versus how much on the other
should be 50 50 but in fact,
when you do the experiment,
as it says here,
you get 40% and 60% in version,
right?
So 80% of it is Rasul [inaudible].
That's what you expect.
That is 40% of right.
40% of lefthanded,
but the other 20% is excess.
In version,
it should have been 100% if there was a plane or intermediate cad ion.
Can anybody see how you might explain this?
Okay.
How could it be that you indeed for MCAT,
but it's not equally attacked from the two faces?
Mostly it's attacked from the face opposite the chloride ion.
Where does the chloride ion came from?
Why should it be mostly opposite where the chloride came from?
Yeah.
Can't hear very well.
Steric hindrance of what?
What's the electrons on that?
Right?
The chloride,
even though it's broken,
the bond for a certain time is still around blocking access to the side it came
from.
Right.
So the idea to explain that that inversion is that that chloride for a short
time is still there even though it's not bonded.
So it temporary blocks the face that would lead to retention to give the same
stereochemistry coming in where the chloride was and you get more of the water
coming in from the opposite face.
So this shortlived ion pair gives an explanation for the net inversion.
Okay.
So even though people would usually say that sn one gives Rassam Ization in
truth,
that doesn't always do so,
although it depends on the solvent because the more quickly,
the more the solvent can stabilize ions,
the faster it can get the eye.
And so apart from one another,
the less of this effect you would have.
So it depends on the polarity of the solvent.
That was acetone and water.
Now when you have,
here's an,
we talked about this elimination reaction that [inaudible] bromide with sodium
hydroxide gives a large amount of the alkene,
but is that process that gives the alkene e one or e two that is,
is the rate determining step formation of the TB cad ion and then the hydroxide
attacks tax it,
or is the rate determining step attack of the hydroxide on a hydrogen pulling it
off at the same time that the chloride leaves?
So how could you tell?
How could you tell whether it's e one or e two
okay,
Luke,
just what about the rate?
That's fine.
See you.
That's what the names mean,
right?
So you could follow the names.
He two means it's by molecular that the rate depends on the concentration of eye
drops side.
If the rate limited step,
we're breaking the bond,
right?
No hydroxide involved there.
So the rate wouldn't depend on that.
So you can look at the overall rate,
not just the percent of alkene because more hydroxide could mean that even
though in the rate determining step,
you made the cat eye and the more hydroxide,
the more hydrogens you pull off,
right?
Compared to water attacking.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so you see,
if you see the rate,
not just the product to you,
the ratio,
but the rate depends on hydroxide,
then it's easy to,
okay.
Another way to see whether the Proton is being pulled away in the rate limiting
step is to look for a kinetic isotope effect.
Remember that the hydrogen is faster than deuterium by a factor of up to about
six or seven.
Usually,
uh,
only when you're breaking the bond and the transition state,
if the transition state is forming the ions and later you break the proton away,
then you wouldn't see a hydrogen being faster than deuterium.
Okay.
Now,
this was a question I asked on an exam once,
a given example of the influence of a change in reacted structure on the ratio
of sn two,
two e two products be a specific and quantitative as you can and uh,
the simplest minded answer to such a thing,
it would be neat to,
to have a more subtle example,
but a really simple one is methyl bromide.
How about the amount of sn two and e two in that case?
Anybody venture a guess?
Okay,
this is in fact a trick question,
Kathy.
There can't,
there is no,
they're not two carbons.
You can't make an alkene and there's no hydrogen on the adjacent carbon.
So obviously that's going to be all sn two.
That's a,
so that was sort of a trick.
Okay.
But then in this one we see,
we've seen from last time that it's much easier to do it with a high
concentration of I dropped side,
it's much easier to do s n two then he too,
to the extent that our apartments to do e two,
that sn two because the uh,
sn two was so hindered.
If you get substitution,
it's sn one and the case,
as we saw last time and looking at the,
at the rates of the various are be ours now.
So these are really drastic ratios.
Now there are two different organic chemical perspectives on situations where
you have drastic ratios.
One is the perspective of a synthetic organic chemist who says it's great to
have drastic ratios because then you have a reliable way to get a really high
yield.
It's not going to be 40,
60,
or something like that.
And you'd have to separate it and throw away the stuff you don't want.
You get all the stuff you want.
That's great.
Okay.
But from a physical,
organic cannabis trying to understand mechanism,
if you have a really drastic ratio,
then the at the energy of activation is quite different between the two.
And you can get an an often get an unambiguous interpretation of what the cause
of the,
uh,
what's determining the rate.
If you can get a really big difference,
you have just a small difference.
You can't,
uh,
be so confident that it's not just some subtle change in salvation or something.
So for example,
uh,
the uh,
10 to the third stearic retardation of ice,
propyl vice via sn two.
You remember you had substitution that methyl at Ethel and ice appropriately,
they got slower and slower.
Ice Appropriate was a thousand times slower than methyl,
so that you,
that's a pretty big effect,
right?
1,000 times 10 to the third,
that meant it must be a four kilocalories per mole at room temperature
difference in those two.
So that's,
that's pretty big.
That's not like half a kilo calorie or something like that.
So you get a factor of a thousand or more often you can be confident in
interpreting or in the case of,
uh,
of a t butyl,
remember it jumped way back up again.
It was accelerated by 10 to the fifth compared to ice of propyl by putting that
next one in,
which showed that there was a new mechanism coming in the formation of the,
of the cat eye and intermediate.
Okay.
Now what if the,
what if the ratio is not drastic?
What if the two products that you could get form in about a 50 50 ratio?
Okay.
The synthetic organic chemist says this is deadly,
right?
Because he's doing a lot of reactions in a row to try to get some product.
If each rack reaction has a 50% yield and you do a whole bunch of them in
sequence.
For example,
if you did 12 steps getting a 50% yield at each step,
you'd have yield at the end of one half to the 12th power 0.02% right?
So a synthetic chemist once a reaction,
that gives a really,
really high yield.
Okay?
Uh,
although it might be possible to have a reaction that doesn't give such a good
yield,
but to tinker around with it and get the yield up so that it becomes acceptable
in a sequence like that.
Okay.
But a physical organic chemist finds such find such a situation valuable because
it's a borderline.
There's,
there's a delicate balance between going this way and going this way,
right?
And now you can see changing this effect,
changing that,
changing the solvent this way,
making it more polar,
less polar.
Putting a methyl group on,
taking a methyl group off,
you can interpret small,
uh,
effects.
So it allows sensitive tests of subtle influences.
For example,
isotope effect.
Remember that the,
that a deuterium isotope effect,
we said the maximum is about a factor of seven usually.
So that's not very big in terms of kilocalories per mole,
but if but,
but even though it's not a very big effect,
even though it's a small thing,
you can,
you can interpret it because you know how,
what,
that it must involve breaking hydrogen away in the rate limiting step.
And finally,
in our discussion of a sn two and e two eliminations,
I'm going to give you a valuable lesson that was taught,
was learned.
He taught himself,
uh,
by Joe David Fine,
who is you see here was the class of 1972 in Yale college and was doing a
undergraduate research during the spring of 1971.
So 40 years ago,
he began this project and he continued it,
uh,
through the summer when he,
lived on York street and then it through the fall and the next spring as a,
as a senior.
So this was his research project.
Now,
what was his research project?
There was an interesting question he wanted to ask that required preparing this
compound.
And the question was this,
if you have a very viscous solvent,
can motion of the pieces be a rate or product determining step?
Usually we think of bond formation or bond breaking being a rate limiting step,
but obviously for two things that to react with one another that they have to
get together.
So that requires motion and if the medium is sufficiently viscous,
it could be that.
And the reaction that follows when they get close together as sufficiently fast.
Then it could be that the rate limiting step would be motion not breaking or
making bonds.
So that was the question that Joe David wanted to find the answer to.
It was whether it was possible that motion would be the rate limiting step.
Even very shuttle.
Subtle.
Pardon me.
Short range motion.
You can,
it's easy to imagine that long range motion could be rate limiting.
For example,
the in free radical chain reactions,
you have radicals floating around.
Once they find one another,
Bingo,
they're gone.
Right.
That's the termination reaction that stops the machines in the free radical
chain reactions.
So obviously what's rate limiting is moving them through the solvent,
but that's long range motion.
How about very subtle motion?
Can it also be rate limiting?
Okay,
so he was gonna,
this is what he was going to do.
He was going to use UV light to knock out a molecule of nitrogen between these
two radicals.
So the two radicals are almost next to one another,
but there's a nitrogen molecule in between.
But if those two radicals are going to react with one another,
they have to get the nitrogen out of the way.
Okay.
So how do they get the nitrogen out of way so they could combine?
Well,
in fact these radical studied in solution don't combine.
Why would those radicals not combined easily and even ideas,
radicals usually too.
So most come together form a bond.
Why not?
In this case,
Lauren?
Right?
It's a question of steric hindrance.
There too many methyl groups to get in the way.
So that's not what happens.
Uh,
so in fact,
what happens instead of that is that you rotate that t butyl radical together
with the nitrogen,
right?
So it's just a rotation.
You don't have to actually move things by translation.
Just rotate them,
okay.
To get that geometry shown at the right.
And now one radical is close enough to the deuterium on the other that you can
get a hydrogen deuterium atom transfer,
which is very exothermic easy and fast,
right?
So that would generate then the alkene or the Alkane by deuterium transfer.
Now there's an alternative reaction to these two radicals.
Does anybody see what it is besides doing the Deuterium Adam transfer?
Okay.
What other action could you imagine,
Debbie?
Okay.
That particular process is called radical pair disproportion nation.
That's another way that radicals could kill one another besides coupling.
Okay?
But the second alternative is to rotate the other group,
right?
The one with hydrogens,
which would give the geometry down on the right,
and then you would transfer a hydrogen atom and that would be very exothermic,
easy,
fast,
and you would get that now.
So there's a competition then between transferring hydrogen and transferring
deuterium.
But what's the rate?
What's the product determining step?
What determines which one you do?
Well,
if it's the hydrogen transfer,
then we know that there'll be a kinetic isotope effect and you'll transfer
hydrogen more often than deuterium.
Right?
But if it's the motion,
then the two rotations should be just about equal.
Okay.
They're not very big effect from deuterium on the rotation.
So all you have to do to answer this question of whether this very subtle,
short range motion,
just this rotation is rate limiting,
is to make this compound photo lies it to knock out the nitrogen and see which
products you get,
whether the deuterium is in the alkane product or the alkene product.
Right?
If it's 50 50 that says that there wasn't a kinetic isotope effect,
hydrogen was not being transferred when the product was being determined,
the rotation was limiting.
Right?
If there is an isotope effect,
then that means that the,
that the,
that the bond breaking,
not the motion was rate limiting.
Okay,
so that's easy.
That's what it says here.
Okay.
So all he had to do then was to prepare this compound.
Then notice how the compound was pretty carefully devised,
not so you can sell it to your neighbor and make a big profit.
But to answer this particular question,
so this is in the same spirit as the Bartlett and Knox paper where the idea was
to make some molecule that was designed to answer a particular question.
Okay.
Now,
often in when you're planning to make something,
you draw a scheme that where the Arrow doesn't show what something goes to
something else.
It shows the backwards.
It's retro synthesis.
That is what could you prepare this compound from what we haven't talked about,
the reactions that we get from that starting material on the right to this
product,
but they,
but by the end of the course,
they'll seem trivial to you.
They're easy reactions that would do that.
Okay?
So if you could prepare this compound t butyl hydrazine,
then you'd be home free according to to,
uh,
what we apply on.
Okay.
So you need t butyl hydrazine now where are you going to get tea?
Butyl hydrazine so it requires having a tea butyl group connected to nitrogen.
Right.
While you can buy hydrazine that's cheap.
You could buy tea,
beautiful chloride.
That's cheap.
You can buy at that time,
40 years ago you could buy a can of it that size for $5 or something like that.
Okay,
so all you have to do is do a substitution reaction where the nitrogen displaces
chloride.
Right.
Does that sound like a good synthetic plan?
Kate,
what do you think about doing,
say an sn?
Two reaction to have the unshared pair on the nitrogen attack.
The carbon displays chloride seem okay to you or not?
So good.
Pardon me?
Yeah,
you can imagine though,
almost lumos any other,
any problems with it?
Hi,
Shar.
Steric hindrance,
right?
What do you have all those methyl groups?
It's hard to get at that carbon and what would happen instead
if you can't do the substitution elimination.
Okay,
so you're going to have,
he too will be much greater than sn two here and in fact he one is greater than
sn one two.
So you're going to get this,
not that you're going to have to figure some other way of making tea,
butyl hydrazine.
Well,
fortunately there was in the literature,
this paper in the Journal of organic chemistry from 1958 about a preparation of
these hydro that wasn't the title of the paper,
but it to make the stuff in the paper they needed to prepare hydrazine's and
they say in this paper that we explored most of the synthetic methods that have
been used for other Al Keel hydrazine's but most failed altogether or gave only
negligible yields,
right?
When you tried to do it with tea.
Beautiful.
Right?
But there was a seldom used method that had been discovered by Cerner and that
worked well,
edited,
involved,
uh,
hydrolyzing this cc c n double bond.
So that reacting with water gave from this half a key tone,
a ketone that I think some of you have seen,
right?
And on the right,
the t butyl hydrazine the compound you want.
Okay,
so hydrolysis of the intermediate,
Benzo for known.
So the idea is to break a CND double bond and put water in there to put oxygen
on the carbon,
the h two of water on the nitrogen,
and you have the uh,
amine you want,
it's connected to another nitrogen and then to t butyl,
right?
And it's very common to change.
See x double bonds into CEO double bonds and h two ax.
And we'll discuss this ad nauseum later on.
Okay.
And notice that this reaction is catalyzed by acid,
right?
The way it happens is you put a proton on this nitrogen,
And then,
uh,
that
resonance structure has the cat eye and on the carbon and that can add water and
get the oxygen on there.
But suppose you protonate the wrong nitrogen.
If you protonate that nitrogen and then shift these electrons in there.
Now you have the t butyl cat ion,
which is going to lose a proton,
give isobutylene and you're lost,
right?
So it says hot acid caused the elimination of the t butyl group.
So you have to be carried out at room temperature.
You don't want to warm it.
Okay?
So fine.
Do it at room temperature.
So this is what Joe David set out to do a he,
the synthesis starts with this compound weirdly enough,
and you have to react it with a grin Yar reagent here,
uh,
which puts the butyl group on the nitrogen.
And then you're going to break that bond,
put oxygen on there at age two on there,
and you're going to have the product you want.
That's the idea.
That's the synthetic scheme.
So in the first place,
it turns out that t butyl grin ar is not the easiest reagent to make,
especially in the summer when it's humid.
So it was hard,
uh,
for,
for Joe,
David the did that,
but do this.
But finally he got this stuff to add there and got the stuff that needed to be
hydrolyzed.
And then he tried to do it.
He worked on this from April to October through the whole summer and never got
it to work.
Okay.
And finally he got very frustrated.
So he,
he telephoned Peter Asmr Smith,
the professor at the University of Michigan who had published that paper in 1958
and asked him what gave,
and this is a page from Joe David Finds Notebook from October,
1971 private communication with Dr Pas Smith.
Most importantly,
he stressed that is published method will not give the desired product.
Instead the t butyl group is lost.
They haven't been able to reproduce lack Chris's results nor to make any more
okay.
Although he feels that hydrolysis in the desired manner is possible if
hydrolysis is killed very rapidly,
he said to quote,
play around with it,
which of course Joe David had been doing from April to October.
So the,
the next comment is the one I really like in his notebook for the sake of public
courtesy and sophistication.
I will reserve my own comments on this subject.
Okay.
Now in preparing for this lecture,
I,
I emailed Joe David Fine,
so there's a happy ending to this rather lack remos story.
He's now a respected professor of dermatology at Vanderbilt and is the world
expert on Epidermal Elias Epidermal lysis below asa,
which is a skin disease.
He's a dermatologist after all and his son graduated from Yale in 2000 and here
he is,
you see wearing his Yale crew tie is very nice guy and he said in a reply email.
He's a fellow of the Royal College of Physicians in London now as well as a
master of public health and an MD.
He said that project and my conversation with that pleasant profit you've
Michigan did teach me more about the rigors and foibles of bench research than
anything that I subsequently experienced as a postdoc at Nih.
It therefore prepared me for many more happily transient foibles during the 19
years that I ran a bench immunology lab at University of Alabama at Birmingham
and University of North Carolina.
As I found out the hard way trying to predict good behavior with cell lines,
antibodies and semi purified proteins was even more subject to random whimsy
than when I was trying to work with relatively straightforward purified
chemicals in a far more structured laboratory setting.
As an Undergrad.
So he,
he feels that this was very good training for him.
Uh,
but the important lesson was learned by me next,
the next year at a Gordon Conference in the summer up in New Hampshire when I
ran my new,
my graduate school friends,
Steven Nelson and professor at the University of Wisconsin,
he said that the way to make tea butyl hydrazine is to react this with this.
Right now,
it's indeed true that 95% of it is the elimination,
right?
But that product is a gas.
So it just goes away.
And the other 5% is the stuff you want.
Furthermore,
it's very easily to easily purified.
You can crystallize it.
So in one day I made 10 grams of it,
right?
This was after Joe David and graduated,
So what's the lesson here?
This,
if you have cheap starting materials,
you don't need a high per se,
that the yield you get isn't the big deal.
If you've got cheap stuff and you can easily do it and purify the product,
that's the way to make this stuff right.
Okay?
So there's a second happy ending that Joe David fine then had a successor the
next year when we actually had the compound,
he was able to make it,
test it and find out that if you have a fluid solvent,
there's an isotope effect.
Hydrogen is transferred more than deuterium.
I had him transfer is rate limiting,
but in a very viscous solvent,
at low temperature,
the kinetic isotope effect disappeared.
It was 50,
50 hydrogen to deuterium transfer because at this demonstrated that motion had
become rate limiting.
So it is possible for very subtle motion to be the rate limiting step in a
reaction.
So there were two happy endings to this.
Joe.
David learned a valuable lesson and uh,
I learned something both from,
uh,
Joe David and from Steve Nelson and from this result.
So this is,
this is the stuff that,
that'll be included on Friday on the exam.
I'm sorry that it's taken so long to do this and I'm going to give a review of
this evening,
but the registrar seems to be having trouble getting into work or something.
I'm not sure.
That's not surprising today.
So we'll have a room in WL h I'm sure,
and I'll email you where it's going to be.
Okay.
Now the next,
uh,
topic is going to be backwards.
What we've been doing,
so what we've been doing is ill substitution and elimination.
And the elimination reaction is of course this,
uh,
where the hydrogen and the leaving group go away.
Proton and leaving group minus typically,
right?
So we have a leaving group.
Now what we're going to the next topic because we're going to be electrophilic
cause it's called addition to alkenes.
Now notice that this is the reverse of e one or e two with some of the names
changed.
So where are we have a proton there.
That's a low Lumo of course,
an electro file someplace where electrons could be easily accommodated,
but we can generalize it.
It doesn't have to be a proton,
it can be any electro file.
Just call it e l okay.
And the thing that was a leaving group,
we're going to change the name of,
it's a high homo,
we're going to call it a nucleophile,
right?
And now with those change names,
we're going to reverse the reaction.
All right.
And take the AL keen to a substituted alkane.
Okay.
Now there are a number of questions involved with this that both ones involve in
mechanism and one involve ones involved in synthetic practicality.
One is what can you make that's a,
that's a synthetic question.
What?
What can elect profile a nucleophile B and you'll see that they could be a wide
range of things.
Then there's a mechanistic question,
is this a homo Lumo kind of reaction or does it involve simply occupied or is it
a free radical reaction?
There's the question of timing.
Do you make both bonds at once or do you make one bond and then the other and if
so,
which?
There's the question of Stereo Chemistry.
Do the electro file a nucleophile come in on opposite sides of the double bond
or on the same side?
And that's particularly relevant.
Of course,
if they're,
if they happen to be in the same molecule,
then almost certainly they have to come in on the same side.
Right?
But if you,
if you come in stepwise one first,
then the other side can flop around,
right?
So you could attack either side of the other one,
even if the two things are coming in from the same side,
you could adapt the opposite face if it was step wise and it rotated.
So that's going to be an interesting question.
Whether the product is from sin or Auntie and we all,
we studied that already in elimination,
whether elimination was sent her Auntie,
and then there's the chemistry,
the question of Riggio Chemistry,
or is it sometimes called orientation,
whether the reaction follows Markov knockoffs rule.
Now,
more cognitive coughs rule,
uh,
happens when you have an unsymmetrical case,
right?
So,
and you're adding Hx,
right?
So,
so you can have x go on the carbon that's more substituted and a name that
sometimes has been given to this as the Matthew rule from this,
uh,
Bible quotation,
Matthew 25,
29 for unto every one that hath shall be given and he shall have abundance.
So the carbon that already has two methyls gets another x,
right?
And h goes to where the ages were.
Right.
And that that's contemporary economics seems often to work that way that the
people that have a lot get a lot.
Right?
So that's one,
that's one role,
that's the Markovnikov rule,
but sometimes it's anti Markovnikov the product puts the hydrogen ware on the
carbon that has more things.
So all these are questions we're now going to address.
Uh,
last year,
uh,
we had a guest lecture from professors equals Siegel from Zurich who talked with
a more synthetic perspective to the class.
If you want us read his lecture,
you can listen to it and watch the,
see what he wrote on the board,
on the web for last year's website.
But anyhow,
from a synthetic perspective,
the idea is you have an alkene and unsymmetrical alkene and you're going to
react it with some ab reagent and put a on one end and be on the other.
And what can a and B B that is,
what products can you make from an alkene?
You can imagine putting two H's on an h and an x and h and n,
O,
h,
two x's,
x and o,
Or you could imagine,
Oh,
H and h.
Now we already had h and o,
h but this is different.
It's a different orientation like that Markovnikov,
anti Markovnikov and the same here with these.
So in the course of the lecture,
he went through and showed a number of reagents and filled in this scheme of
what happens and what kind of stereo chemistry you have and so on.
So that's synthetic,
uh,
motivation for studying these things.
What compounds can you make from alkenes?
Right?
But we're going to take,
you won't be surprised,
a little more physical approach and look first at the thermodynamics stability
of some of the Alkenes,
uh,
and then,
at the how they react.
Now you wonder where you get this information about stability of compounds.
A great place to get it is from this website,
which I have on the,
which I can get on the other computer here.
If you put NIST,
which is the National Institute of Science and technology into Google,
you get this.
And the very first thing you see is chemistry web book.
So if you click there,
you get the chemistry web book.
And I think I've got that here too.
And then you can search in that web book by different criteria.
And the easy one is formula for our purposes.
And let's suppose we're interested in beauty means.
So we have si pho for h eight,
oops,
not d h eight.
Okay.
And let's,
uh,
let's work in kilocalories,
not in the SIU units.
Okay.
So let's search and see what we can find.
So here's what I just found and it's also on here.
Uh,
so I have one beauty to beauty in two flavors,
Z and e,
CIS and Trans.
Uh,
then I have,
uh,
two methyl one propane and I assume are in cycle of butane,
also methyl Cyclo,
propane,
and to beauty a generic that is not,
not separated this isomers.
So let's just look at one beauty in and see what kind of information is
available.
Okay.
So we see there's all kinds of data available here.
Gas Phase,
Thermo Chemistry,
condensed phase,
thermo chemistry phase changes,
uh,
blob reaction,
Thermo Chemistry.
That's particularly interesting.
Let's,
but let's first look at a,
at a gas phase.
Thermal Chemistry.
Okay,
so here we see the heat of formation in the gas phase is almost zero.
It has about the same energy as the elements graphite and hydrogen do,
right?
And if you look at the heat of combustion,
it's this,
and what's particularly valuable is you can see how well it's known,
what the error limits are.
And then it's been,
these data have been evaluated by here,
als,
which is al Fevi,
uh,
Liebman and Stein.
But it also gives where the stuff really came,
where the information came from.
So if you click on that,
you get these,
uh,
the,
that,
those things came from process and Marin and Rossini.
Now this Rossini is not the guy who wrote the barber of Seville.
It's,
it's Frederick Rossini who is,
who was a great,
uh,
thermo thermodynamicists who measured lots and lots of these things.
Notice incidentally that also there's a lot of data from the thermodynamic
research center at Texas a and M in Texas.
Now,
Rossini started that,
the National Bureau of standards,
which is what's become Nis t when it got renamed,
then he went to Notre Dame and then he went to Rice in Houston.
Now some of you are from Houston.
Why do you think somebody who's particularly interested,
why should somebody who lives in Houston be interested in,
in the energies of hydrocarbons?
Major bazillion hydrocarbons.
Why
Cassie oil,
right.
This started in 1942,
the American Petroleum Institute started a big project to determine
thermodynamic properties of all the things that could be in,
in petroleum,
right and refined petroleum and so on.
So this was done first at the National Bureau of Standards Than,
than to,
uh,
Mellon Institute in Pittsburgh as it was then.
And then he went to Rice.
So this [inaudible] there's a method in what they're doing here.
Now,
let me back up.
Uh,
okay.
So we've got that.
If we,
uh,
if we go down a little further,
we could look at reaction,
thermo,
chemistry.
Uh,
now,
so this is the heat evolved when you,
uh,
when you,
when you do a reaction.
So notice that here's one beauty in becomes to be routine trans to beauty.
And here are different people who measured it either by equilibrium constant or
by a ISO thermal calorimetry.
And these are the values that they deserve.
They obtained.
And you can see they're pretty similar to one another that the,
that,
that the tube you teen sis,
the Trans to beauty is more stable than one beauty by about three kilocalories
per mole.
Okay.
Uh,
now if we,
if you can go down in this,
let's see if I got it
to other reactions.
Yeah.
Uh,
these are different reactions.
There's adding Hbr to one beauty.
Uh,
the one I'm looking for.
Here's,
here's going to,
here's go into the,
to the sis to beauty,
right?
Uh,
oh,
that's the first one I had.
So cis and Trans and you see it's a different energy involved in going to CIS
and trans.
But the one I really looking for is a little further down
here in the middle here is adding hydrogen to get butane.
Right?
So here are the here are
for that.
Uh,
for that reaction.
Wait,
I'm,
I'm out of sync with what's over here.
This is,
this is a number of,
this is adding to the,
to give.
This is changing one beauty to assist to be a teen and here all these uh,
values for that.
And the next one over here on the web is the one I've just talking about,
30 kilocalories for that.
But you can also do it and I'm not going to do it over there for the sake of
time,
you can see how much energy is given off and adding hydrogen to,
to assist,
to beauty and how much to trans to buting.
Now these differences in energy that you get here,
uh,
wait here,
now
all give the same product.
Now there's a big advantage to doing a reaction that's not very endothermic or
exothermic.
It's not like combustion,
which is 600 calories per mole,
right?
To take one thing to another that involves rather small amount of energy like
this adding hydrogen to the alkene and to take three different isomers and
convert them to the same thing.
You see what the advance why that's a nice experiment to do.
Yes,
pardon?
Well,
you could make
more,
but not many people want to make butane,
right?
You get that for free or from the petroleum to begin with.
It's for purposes of measurement that it's important,
right?
Because if you're measuring a small amount of energy and make a 2% error,
it's not very much.
If you're measuring 600 calories and make a 2% error,
that's 12 kilocalories,
right?
But you can,
but here you see these errors are a part in 200,
right?
Apart in 300 part in 300.
So,
so now you know all these compounds relative to the same compound to very high
precision,
which means you know them relative to one another,
right?
So that's the way to really,
uh,
get the data properly.
Uh,
so here's a table from a,
from a textbook,
I think it's the Jones textbook which gives these things.
But you've seen now where it really comes from,
from this,
uh,
from this NIST web book.
And what,
uh,
here are data I collected for the,
from the NIST web books for the heck scenes.
And you'll notice that a whole bunch of them were done by professor.
Why Barry in the eighties and nineties,
nineties.
The guy who talked to you last year,
and this is a problem to do after the exam.
So it could be due next Wednesday,
say something like that a week from today.
But to try to look at these numbers here,
the relative stability of the heck scenes
and see whether it's consistent with what you,
what you find for the beauty means in terms of the relative energies that is,
are there regularities of the energy between CIS and Trans Double Bond of the
difference between a double bond at the end of the chain and a double bond in
the middle of the chain.
Can we make generality that way?
So that's a fun project to look at.
But the first thing to do is to get to the exam on Friday.
So I'll talk to you this evening about that.
That's it.